liebe freunde meine damen und herren
dies ist unser sechster parteitag und
ich habe die ehre ihn eröffnen zu dürfen
nun ist sechs keine runde zahl aber sie
könnte für uns einer wichtigen werden
denn es besteht die aussicht dass die
partei mit ihrem sechsten parteitag
erwachsen wird keine sorge liebe freunde
erwachsen heißt nicht angekommen und
schon gar nicht angepasst erwachsen
heißt dass wir einen teilweisen
generationswechsel solidarisch
vollziehen wenn ich heute als einer der
gründer der partei platz machen für
einen jüngeren dann geschieht das in
freundschaft und niemand muss die sorge
haben dass ich morgen
öffentlichkeitswirksam entdecker dass
die partei nicht mehr die meine ist weil
sie angeblich zu rechts geworden sein
nein liebe freunde diese partei ist
genau richtig und mir seit genau richtig
und weil ich nach menschlichem ermessen
heute nicht zur wahl stehen nehme ich
mir die freiheit zu einigen
grundsätzlichen ja auch
zukunftsweisenden bemerkungen liebe
freunde wir haben zusammen etwas
geschafft was niemand 2013 für möglich
gehalten hätte wir haben dieses land
verändern und wir haben den menschen
eine stimme gegeben die sich allein kaum
noch trauten der auflösung unseres
nationalstaates in der märkischen
willkommenskultur zu widersprechen und
liebe freunde
vor allem auch zu widerstehen wir haben
den vielen mut gemacht die uns heute
schon wählen und wir sind anderen eine
hoffnung die heute noch zweifel
in deutschland gibt es nun eine
politische größe die das deutsche
nationale interesse für die europa und
welt starts träumereien der grünen
schwarz-roten deutschland ab scharfer
stellt und die europäische
zusammenarbeit nicht als das aufgeben
nationaler souveränität begreift
liebe freunde wenn laut einer allensbach
umfrage mehr als zwei drittel der eliten
uns als ernsthafte gefahr für das land
sprich für sich selbst betrachten dann
haben wir als partei des volkes und der
kleinen leute vieles richtig gemacht und
dafür danke ich euch
[Applaus]
der chefredakteur einer großen deutschen
zeitung schlägt mir kürzlich privat
polemisch was ist aus ihnen geworden
das ist aus mir geworden dass ich mit
euch zusammen diese partei an diese
stelle geführt haben
wir wollen ich weiß es sagt sich so
leicht
in deutschland gibt es nun eine
politische kraft
denn diese kraft zu formen hat kräftige
koste unsere kräfte hass und hetze derer
denen wir ihren politischen
alleinvertretungsanspruch streitig
machen sind ungeheuerlich da werden
autos angezündet seele und konten
gekündigt hotelreservierungen verweigert
und menschen tätlich angegriffen
sie nennen uns nazis faschisten und
sogar rechts terroristen
dabei sind wir nur menschen die dieses
land anders als frau roth lieben und es
deshalb verteidigen wollen und werden
und liebe freunde da das alles noch
nicht geholfen hat wurde der
verfassungsschutz zum büttel der
herrschenden degradiert ich weiß nicht
mehr freunde
der druck ist gewaltig und jeder von uns
kann geschichten erzählen von
ausgrenzung und mobbing
doch gerade liebe freunde weil das so
ist müssen wir ebenso klug wie standhaft
sein und es unseren feinden so schwer
wie möglich machen
letztlich wird das
bundesverfassungsgericht darüber zu
entscheiden haben ob in diesem land
opposition gegen eine falsche
regierungspolitik verfassungswidrig ist
liebe freunde noch gibt es richter in
karlsruhe
und ich bin sicher dass wir diesen kampf
gemeinsam gewinnen werden
das heißt aber auch dass wir den weg
einer patriotischen demokratischen und
bürgerlichen volkspartei den wir
eingeschlagen haben weitergehen müssen
dazu gibt es tatsächlich keine
alternative
liebe freunde und ich weiß einige von
uns träumen manchmal den traum einer
kleinen sozialrevolutionären partei die
französischen gelb besten lassen grüßen
nur liebe freunde dieser traum ist
irreal
der vierzehnte juli 1789 hat in
deutschland keine tradition
wir stürmen keine basti und wir sind
nicht gut in revolution 1848 so wenig
wie 1918 und das sage ich nicht für
unsere freunde in anführungsstrichen vom
verfassungsschutz die natürlich auch
hier dabei sind
ich sage es war eine richtige analyse
die voraussetzung für den politischen
erfolg
und diese analyse besagt dass wir nur
bei demokratischen wahlen so stark
werden können dass es nicht länger
möglich sein wird uns von der
gestaltungsmacht dieses landes
auszuschließen
damit gebe ich nicht für die anpassung
an eine verrottete cdu habe für einen
realistischen demokratischen weg unser
land ist heute gespalten zwischen dienen
für die der nationalstaat heimat und
bezugspunkt des politischen handelns ist
und der abgehobenen grünen lebenswelt
globaler eliten deren heimat die welt
ist dann zwischen zerbröseln cdu und spd
weil sie sich nicht zwischen nationaler
politik und abgehobenen
internationalismus oder um sind meine
lieblings politiker heiko maas zu sagen
so genannten regelbasierten
multilateralismus entscheiden würden
liebe freunde
es ist schon schwer zu ertragen dass
angela merkel heute den platz otto von
bismarcks einnimmt aber heiko maas an
der stelle rathenaus und striesen uns zu
sehen übersteigt jede schmerzgrenze
die spd ist schon fast ruiniert bei der
cdu hat die zersetzung gerade erst
bekommen deren ende sollten wir im
interesse unseres landes nicht abwarten
liebe freunde es ist nicht sicher damit
zu rechnen dass die cdu völlig so fällt
aber es ist sehr wohl damit zu rechnen
dass die einfachen mitglieder der cdu
ihren führungen die frage nach
bürgerlichen mehrheiten stellen
thüringen und die 17 kommunalpolitiker
waren erst der anfang denn die
unsinniger die wirtschaftsfeindlichen
kompromisse sein werden die grüne in
koalitionen der cdu zumuten und die
entlassungen in der automobilindustrie
sind erst der anfang
desto vernehmbarer wird der ruf nach
einer alternative sein
und wenn grüne rote und dunkelroten
zusammengehen wird der tag kommen an dem
eine geschwächte cdu nur noch eine
option hat uns ja liebe freundin ich
weiß
auch hier gibt es wünsche und träume und
ich kann den traum einer endgültig
überwunden merkel cdu persönlich gut
nachvollziehen
dennoch sollten wir mit der möglichkeit
rechnen dass sich die vielen in der
union die ähnlich denken wie wir von der
last dieses erbes befreien und zu einer
vernunftgeleiteten national orientierten
politik zurückhaltend liebe freunde ich
fand deshalb den brief unseres freundes
yorker anwalt boeing einen klugen
eröffnungsshow was heißt das nun für uns
es heißt dass wir unseren weg
weitergehen ohne anpassung oder gar
anpasser rein dass wir die
zukunftsfähigkeit unseres volkes in den
mittelpunkt unserer arbeit stellen und
manche historischen auseinandersetzungen
zu denen auch ich manchmal neigen in den
hintergrund rücken
liebe freunde eine partei ist eine
kampfgemeinschaft zur erreichung
bestimmter ziele
deshalb ist die meinungsfreiheit des
grundgesetzes auch weiter als die
meinungs- toleranz in einer partei es
ist von der meinungsfreiheit des
grundgesetzes gedeckt staufenberg einen
verräter und weit weg zu nennen aber das
ethos unserer partei verbietet eine
solche meinung weil sie moralisch falsch
und verwerflich ist
viele freunde das soll es auch schon
sein für zeit dass ich zur eröffnung
unseres parteitages ein paar
grundsätzliche bemerkungen gemacht habe
aber mich treibt die sorge um dass wir
den mantel der geschichte verfehlen und
bismarcks bild zu bleiben die chance die
wir mit der afg haben kommt nicht zurück
wenn sie vertan ist und deshalb liebe
freunde ist auch dieser parteitag einen
meilenstein sozusagen zur bewahrung
unseres landes und unseres volkes ich
danke euch
[Applaus]